European Union regulations
which bans over 1600 chemicals
This whole idea that EU products are
safer because they ban more stuff
really bothers me because it's just not true
unsafe products are banned in
the US including if they have
unsafe levels of anything it's called adulterated
The US law has a list of 11
ingredient categories that
are explicitly banned but this isn't meant
to be everything these are just examples
The EU's list also isn't meant to
include everything they've just
got more examples and their list
includes a whole bunch of things
that no one would ever intentionally put
into cosmetics like radioactive substances
There are lots of examples of the FDA
saying that unsafe products are illegal
because they contain unsafe levels of
something that wasn't on that list of 11
so for example these products had
harmful levels of bacteria or mould